travis barker's kids thanking fans for
support to mid the drummer's health
battle
more legal trouble for amber hurd it's a
sad state of affairs that that made
such headline global news
stranger things cast dishes on the
show's emotional season 4 finale it's
off the bat not looking great for us no
it's not
it's been never done
[Music]
and a look at how the summer's most
viral movie scene came together i
remember passing out with like three
different cakes in my hand et's the
download starts right now
[Music]
we begin with an update on travis barker
his loved ones are speaking out and
thanking fans for their outpouring of
support after his recent health scare
travis was rushed to the hospital on
tuesday where an e.t store says he was
diagnosed with pancreatitis amid the
health battle his daughter alabama took
to instagram posting a photo of her hand
next to his adding thank you guys for
all the prayers and love i appreciate
you and love all of you the drummer's
step-daughter auntiana de la hoya is
also expressing gratitude on her ig
writing thank you for the outpouring of
love and prayers sent our way at this
time it is heard felt and appreciated
now on to justin bieber who appears to
be on the road to recovery after his
ramsey hunt syndrome diagnosis the
singer was spotted leaving life
hyperbarics this week a source tells e.t
justin has actually been using
hyperbaric chambers for years for health
and healing purposes our source adds he
got into the practice as a way to detox
and heal after years of neglecting his
health and body justin revealed his
diagnosis to fans earlier this month
revealing his health struggles left half
of his face paralyzed and haley gave an
update on her husband's condition to
good morning america he's doing really
well he is getting better every single
day
he's feeling
a lot better and obviously was just a
very
scary and random situation to happen
now travis barker's buddy machine gun
kelly had a health scare of his own even
though it was self-inflicted he's
telling seth meyers why he smashed a
champagne glass on his forehead you know
when you uh
clink a champagne glass with a fork to
give him his attention to start a toast
yeah yeah
yeah i didn't have a fork okay
so i just clinked it
on my head in medicine they call that
asking for it
[Applause]
yeah so i had a serious case of that
last night
so this is what mgk looked like before
he cleaned himself up now moving on to
another kelly kelly clarkson she is
admitting how hard her divorce is the
singer and ex brandon blackstock were
married for seven years they just
finalized their divorce in march now
she's opening up to apple once the
global chart show about how she's
turning that experience into new music
i've never had this difficult of a
project and it's been like two years and
not easy with kids especially that makes
it just a whole different dynamic my
outlet in general is just writing
i mean i have to be completely honest
but that's a hard thing to navigate
right
turning now to amber hurd just weeks
after that high-profile defamation case
against johnny depp she's facing renewed
scrutiny down under
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
amber is still on the hook for more than
10 million dollars after that verdict a
month ago and now we've learned she's
still embroiled in another case in
australia a spokesperson for the
department of agriculture water and
environment tells et they're
investigating allegations that amber
lied under oath during court proceedings
for the 2015 illegal importation of her
two dogs into the country
you'll recall when amber and johnny were
still married they brought their two
yorkshire terriers pistol and boo to
australia without declaring them despite
the country's strict quarantine policy
it's something johnny discussed with
jimmy kimmel he went to australia didn't
shooting parts of the caribbean did you
smuggle the dogs into the country no the
dogs were
we
we were under the
impression that we had all the paperwork
done for the dogs we were there with the
dogs in front of everybody
there might have been other things
smuggled
in july 2015 amber was charged with two
counts of illegally importing the
animals she later pleaded guilty to
falsifying travel documents and how are
the dogs are they good yes they're good
despite attempts by certain
rogue
thug australian government officials
and the following year johnny and amber
issued this apology australia is a
wonderful island with a treasure trove
of unique plants animals and people it
has to be protected
things are about to turn upside down
because the dramatic conclusion to
stranger things season four drops
tonight i spoke with the cast about the
emotional final two episodes
he's not going to stop
not until he's taken everyone everything
is driven by
love and survival
your friends
have lost
it's off the bat not looking great for
us no it's not it's been never done
these final two episodes are super sized
in fact chapter nine is the length of a
movie and while we won't spoil it for
you creators the duffer brothers promise
a much darker finale and fate for the
hawkins crew we always survive uh and
and work best as a team and now we don't
have that that option there are
characters who are in real real danger
that is surprising i know you're framed
so things to watch out for one more kate
bush
[Music]
she gets her life saved by kate bush by
kate bush
two what will happen with vecna a
behind-the-scenes secret jamie campbell
bauer who spent eight and a half hours
transforming into the villainous
creature actually used his creepy voice
between takes
three get ready for a stranger things
spin-off the duffer brothers haven't
officially announced anything but they
teased quote there's more exciting
stories to tell it's going to be
different than what anyone is expecting
including netflix when we watch the
episodes i'm like wow i'm just watching
this as a fan i didn't see any of this
on the day
i cannot wait for the finale i'm
probably going to pull an all-nighter
i'm just going to roll right in from
watching it no sleep tonight so extra
concealer for you tomorrow night this is
like warts and all let's go with it no
makeup
all right well stranger things fans
clearly can't get enough of season four
top gun maverick fans can't get enough
of this iconic scene and now we're
getting a look at the making of those
magical moments
[Music]
yeah we just pumped it up
getting everything immaculately perfect
and ready for the iconic scene
this is a good one i don't know if
you've tried this
i'm not going to sign off on that
it's more about more reps with less
weight these guys have no idea what
they're doing you want the opportunity
to have that senior movie that people
just have fun and dance whatever it is
now that unforgettable scene has made
star miles teller a social media
sensation i mean thanks to this
shirtless shimmy right here you know he
told et shooting it was no walk in the
park actually you finished the beach
scene
you then celebrate i remember passing
out with like three different cakes in
my hand and then they call you a couple
weeks later and they're like we gotta
reshoot that you're like oh my god
so mad well here's the thing it doesn't
seem to have mattered because top gun
maverick is now well past 1 billion
dollars at the global box office and
really you couldn't ask for a better
team building exercise by the way it
looks exactly like this before we come
in here on stage and do the show
speaking of teams it's been 15 years
since the autobots rolled out for their
first live-action film when michael
bay's transformers hit the big screen
it's the biggest movie of this summer
that's weird i just wouldn't peg you for
mechanical
was the kissing scene awkward
hell no
but it was it was enjoyable i mean i'm
just talking from my standpoint now
shia found love on screen
battled shape-shifting robots
and brought cgi to life
yeah 70's challenging sure i mean
because you gotta conjure it all up
and there's nothing to react to or
respond to he was just 21 at the time
co-star megan a month older and both
were just hitting it big right thank god
they're here okay
about the worst day ever e.t was behind
the scenes of the near 710 million
dollar blockbuster the first of six
movies so far in the franchise
action-loving michael bay directed and
it was one of the first big movies for
josh dumas how's it feel up there it was
good
and tyrese we were there as they filmed
in a scorching new mexico desert i
started out in the desert in 180 degree
heat sand dunes
and michael almost passed out
well then what's your secret to staying
cool
i'm just cool babe
sorry are there a lot of stunts for them
you're talking to me
of course there's a lot of stuff
but it's fun yeah it's fun which one of
us is sexier i think we both have our
own sexy thing going he could never pull
the girls out pool and vice versa
but us together
man we gonna shut it damn
bring the rain
[Music]
on to another movie milestone yeah grab
your chanel boots book your tickets to
paris because the devil wears prada is
celebrating it's sweet 16.
there you are emily how many times do i
have to scream your name
actually it's andy
meryl streep's performance as ice queen
fashion editor miranda priestley snagged
the actress her 14th oscar nod and anne
hathaway's andy proved her acting chops
far exceeded the princess diaries i
really did everything i could think of
uh
meryl is known to be chummy on sets but
for this film she kept her distance to
keep the on-screen tensions authentic
she pulled me aside at the beginning of
the film and said listen i just want to
say i think you're perfect i'm so
excited that we're going to be working
together
but that's the last nice thing i'm going
to say to you and it was i didn't try to
stay in the character but i'm naturally
in a bad mood so
um it was not that difficult and turns
out we almost didn't get the now
memorable pairing during negotiations
for the part streep was ready to walk
over what she felt was a low offer so
producers doubled it on the spot to keep
her as for anne hathaway she wasn't the
first choice to play andy rachel mcadams
was and the 2006 film also put newcomer
emily blunt on the map just one stomach
flew away from my goal weight
she later went on to reunite with meryl
twice for the musicals into the woods
and mary poppins returns i've known her
for many years and and i it doesn't mean
i'm any less in awe of her and what she
does
but i know her better now she's such a
broad you know she's so cool and fun and
smart and she charms everyone i always
sort of um
uh
harass emily in every film we're in so
i'm looking forward to that
i can't shake her i mean i've done three
movies with her now
but this is
this is i think the most beautiful gift
she's given to the world this
performance and this this movie
and speaking of cast reunions anne
hathaway would go on to work alongside
stanley tucci once again and the witches
on hbo max we get to kick up with
stanley and get to play totally
different characters and get to be weird
and silly
uh it was really special but what can we
do we can't go
that was great and she was terrorizing
me and i suppose i terrorized her a
little bit in the first movie
i don't think i need these miranda hired
me she knows what i look like do you
the devil wears prado went on to make
over 325 million dollars that's nearly
10 times what it costs to make but oh
those fashions the handbags and i think
there were sixty of them you know many
many many of them cost over ten thousand
dollars anne's favorite dress this
gorgeous galliano gown like when you put
it on it felt like like it was made of
sex and it was just
absolute heaven to wear but once filming
was over the ladies were ready to get
back into their jeans and t-shirts i
said are you gonna like become a like a
real fashion girl after this she says oh
god no and i was like i am so there but
i defected first i went out like three
weeks later and bought a proper dress
speaking of fashion this summer it's all
about showing some skin not just arms
and legs we're talking about scalps too
okay so the hadith sisters clearly got
this memo gigi is practically
unrecognizable going bald with just a
touch of bangs it's the new look y'all
walking in marc jacobs show in new york
city now gigi's little sister bella was
incognito too posting these photos to
the gram i'm sorry i love the wording
just a hint of fact just like your
little snapchat
uh check out these looks from louis
vuitton's men's show so we got ginormous
boom boxes lots of color and splashes of
pokemon
we've all heard of going green but
spanish fashion house low is taking it
next level the models actually had grass
growing from their clothes so designer
jonathan anderson's goal here was to
raise awareness about nature he threw in
some clothes with working screens to
help drive that point home but who needs
actual clothes
undies is the new vibe well at least for
designer tom brown his new men's
collection features jock straps chaps
bikinis and micro mini skirts all for
men fashion yeah i don't think i could
pull it off but you know good for these
guys all right guys now on to our
favorite rambling redhead jen todrick
she's back for season two of no demo
renault on hgtv 18's lauren zema is
giving us some behind the scenes secrets
so we're gonna have brick here break
here amazing pendants new island my
beams what do you call your signature
jen todrick bun it needs a name eight
day dirty hair and my mom and i are
watching a rerun and i was like mom who
wears hair like that on national
television and we both just laughed at
each other like we were laughing in
silence because no one i don't know i'm
digging it and so are the fans jen and
her bun are back for season two of no
demo renault what makes hgtv's thursday
show special is that the mom of three
sticks to the house's original floor
plan aka no moving walls and no major
demo
[Music]
what can you do to make the space bigger
without that demo
bigger without the demo paint is just a
beautiful magical thing the right paint
choice last season the renault budgets
were between 30 and 70 thousand dollars
now well we got one word for you
inflation 80 was our lowest budget this
season labor is so much more expensive
than even materials most of the time now
it's nuts
what was the budget on this kitchen
budget altogether was 85 for both spaces
okay tell me about this sink that looks
very fun these things are really popular
right now and you get all these cool
like accessories right like strainer
jenna i don't cook what is this oh this
is strainer
i thought it was i thought we were
cutting it i thought it was so heavy
good cheese grater like a real big one i
love honestly you probably could yeah
from the back yeah
oh
my goodness well while lz tries to
figure that out we are moving on to
singer johnny orlando who's telling us
all about his debut album and the
artists that bring him inspiration
really eilish sailing
she's like she wrote a song about like
some gruesome stuff nevertheless you
could do that
and get ready to rock your body
[Music]
because the backstreet boys are
celebrating a major milestone when et's
the download returns
[Music]
[Music]
that was blur the latest single from
singer johnny orlando who joins me now
welcome cool how's it going i'm good i
bet it feels real good to be you right
now though it does it does right
you've been working hard on this
upcoming album but let's talk about blur
that single right there i need to know
the inspo behind it because as i read
this is a story about someone who kind
of came in clutch on a night where you
needed it huh yes well the song it's not
a true story is basically i was in the
session
and the producer rents played at that
sample at the beginning of it in a blur
and you're like blurry that's kind of
cool i don't think that's been done
before so we kind of we based the song
around that sample
[Music]
is it fun for you to kind of explore
different characters stories and worlds
in your music like that
for sure i love that that was i never
really realized that you could do that
because you hear people talk about
songwriting and it's like oh yeah this
is very personal yes experience to me
which is cool but i heard like billy
eilish say like
it's like she wrote a song about like uh
some gruesome stuff and uh obviously
not not applicable to her life right
that's really sick i
never realized you could do that
[Music]
well blur is totally a breadcrumb right
you're about to service a whole meal
with your debut album how excited are
you to give that to the world knowing
how long and how hard you've been
working on it excited also very nervous
yeah then when you put it out it all
becomes uh
like real in a way so and kind of scary
very scary
my debut album as well so yeah um but
yeah are you feeling the love from the
fans i feel like
hopefully they're kind of helping you
curb those nerves a little bit for sure
[Applause]
here's the album right here it's all the
things that could go wrong uh so you've
been working on it for like what a year
and a half now
um
like two weeks yeah two years yeah like
a year and a half okay
yeah we started conceptualizing it like
two years ago yeah um and even before
that well listen you cover a lot of
ground on this record i mean from themes
of anxiety even social media and of
course relationships overthinking in
relationships how's it been like for you
to kind of open up so much in your music
it's really not it's a bit scary a
little bit yeah but mostly just like in
sessions uh like writing sessions having
to actually talk about that stuff is
is uh
a bit apprehensive to do it at first but
yeah uh once you kind of get over that
fear it's a lot easier to
for me at least to like tell the world
things than to tell people i actually
know
[Music]
you have such a huge following right
like 25 million fans on social media
you're the number one universal music
group artist on tick tock with over 8.5
billion views does the idea of that
number of people kind of watching you
overwhelm you
um
no just because you can't even grasp it
really like imagine eight million people
i can't
what does that look like i have no i
have no idea i have no idea so
you know i just see the love and i see
the support
[Applause]
[Music]
good thing we know where to find you're
actually on social media we have that
because it's going for us well thank you
so much for being here thank you
now under exclusive with country singer
mickey guyton she's making fourth of
july history this weekend while also
celebrating her little man's new
milestones
he's starting to say so many words
he can say up he can say fish
he can say no very very well
and god forbid i've cussed in front of
him and he's repeated that
well you can bet 16 month old grayson
will be watching his mama's every move
when she hosts a capital fourth monday
on pbs only we were behind the scenes
with mickey getting ready for the big
show which will also be broadcast to
troops around the world on the american
forces network
the most dazzling display of fireworks
anywhere in the usa live from washington
dc
it's a capital fourth it's going to be a
huge huge cast darin chris cynthia
arrivo yolanda adams cheetah rivera andy
grammer i'm gonna sing the national
anthem i'm gonna do it again
[Applause]
of course mickey kicked off 2022 singing
at the super bowl and now she's making
history as the youngest person ever to
host the special which is wild i did not
know that so thank you this'll mean i'm
just
the pressure
no pressure
[Music]
everybody
rock your body right
back straight back all right
that is a song that will truly stand the
test of time but for now everybody
can't think you can't not you're 25
years old yeah off the boy band
self-titled album everybody not such
everybody included an iconic haunted
mansion themed music video with some
killer choreography those dance moves
helped earned bsb the best group video
trophy at the 1998 mtv video music
awards the track actually became
certified platinum in the states and
became the band's second top 10 single
i guess it hasn't sunk in very
flattering very flattering
sixteen years after its release
everybody got new life and gave us life
y'all after being featured in the
credits of seth rogens this is the end
[Applause]
fast forward to this year and the guys
are still rocking together on their dna
world tour backstreet boys represents
like a really special place in time with
you know nostalgic music and it makes
people happy
next year the five are celebrating their
30th anniversary here's what they told
et about marking the milestone with a
second vegas residency we would like to
we're we're discussing that possibility
after this tour
so in that interview i told them okay
you guys celebrate your 30th anniversary
as i celebrate my 30th birthday with the
biggest residency we're all going to
vegas
[Laughter]
all right guys that's gonna do it for us
today until tomorrow goodbye
[Music]